denis blum président de la sieste
l'association des cinémas indépendants
de l'est
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on vient donc de
l'évoquer les lieux culturels ne
pourront pas rouvrir le 7 janvier quelle
est votre réaction à cette annonce de
gabriella talent une fois de plus
effectivement c'est une déception mais
globalement vie attendions sachant que
effectivement réouvrir ici des mois dans
dans une semaine il ya quand même une
mise en route à faire notamment avec les
distributeurs de films mais le site
aujourd'hui par rapport au premier clic
mans nous avons des filles la reprise
avec la bonne et que au moment de la
fermeture fin octobre la fréquentation
été bonnes donc pour l'instant nous
avons nous avons des films mais il faut
quand même remettre la machine en route
elle ne connaît pas du jeu aura pas de
réouverture est aussi et pas de date
avancée par d'abriel attal est ce que
vous envisagez des actions pour faire
réagir le gouvernement
je pense qu'il y aura de toute manière
au niveau national avec les partenaires
les autres partenaires de la culture
comme ç'avait été le cas notamment au
moment du dieu du référé qui nous de les
raisons par rapport la discrimination
dont nous étions victimes et donc de ce
côté là je pense que de nouveaux y aura
réaction mais je le redis nous une fois
on ne peut pas et au niveau des théâtres
c'est pareil remettre en route du jour
en me disant pour des oubliés de moi ça
n'est pas aussi nous difficilement
possible c'est à dire que même si vous
avez une date qui est avancé par le
gouvernement il vous faut encore un
certain temps pour pouvoir accueillir du
public qu'est ce que vous devez faire
concrètement si le gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous pouvez sans doute
réouvrir on peut envisager une
réouverture très sérieusement à la fin
du mois de janvier
on peut se mettre en ordre de bataille
bush où je rentrais à ce moment là mais
comme je le disais effectivement il y as
d un certain nombre de dispositions
notamment techniques avec le disent avec
les distributeurs
il faut aussi refaire vivre
les films auprès du grand public le
grand public ne va pas assumer dans les
salles sont les dix films que soit le
chemin annoncé savoir ce qui est
impossible ou non de mettre la fiche est
donc tout ça effectivement fait que par
rapport à d'autres types de commerces ce
sans doute une ouverture comme ça du
jour au lendemain ce sera chaque point
de doha n'est pas envisageable
est ce que vous considérez que c'est une
crise inédite pour le secteur les
conséquences de cette pandémie selon le
centre national du cinéma et de l'image
animée la fréquentation des cinémas
fermés donc près de la moitié de l'année
a chuté de presque 70 % en 2020 oui
c'était effectivement une chute une
chute énorme
effectivement pour le pour la remise en
route ça va ça va la donne va changer
parce que bon il ya certes des films qui
sont déjà prêts depuis un moment il ya
une production et qui est en cours et ce
qu'il va y avoir un engorgement au
niveau de la réouverture à nos gorges
mans des sorties beaucoup de questions
se posent aujourd'hui
quant à la fréquentation on parlait on a
entendu des versions de personnes tout à
l'heure qui parlait des plateformes
effectivement peut craindre qu'une
partie du public directement maintenant
vers l'est vers les places donc pour
nous sans doute que le cinéma a déjà
vécu beaucoup de crises il existe depuis
125 ans depuis 125 ans il en crise et
s'en est toujours sorti plutôt bien
sorti moi je suis confiant sur le fait
que les le public retourne dans les
salles de cinéma
mais il faut sans doute s'attendre à une
fréquentation qui ne sera plus celle que
nous avons connue notamment au cours de
l'année 2010 nurse qui avait été très
très bonne merci beaucoup denis blum
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous êtes président de la sieste
l'association des cinémas indépendants
de l'est merci